couple things I can't oversell yourself
on this decision at 20 years old that
I'm not capable of building a business
or I'm just a creator and a Salesman is
ludicrous for justice how are you good
mine's a disaster
you forget the cadence of the door when
they're not here every day push not
though how's it going you know you
started with a very good way yeah yeah
one of the advantages I probably not
success in that way but I told your
exact you're going right down the exact
right path which is you know then the
floor and iris which is I know what's up
man right up a god you're here get in
here
when you're coming from that high the
plane and expectations we may not be
enjoying it because of that and so you
need to create the bucket that helps
operate it I had the luxury abused years
of doing it where Wine Library yeah
that's when I had a railroad it was
clear to sell a hundred cases but this
is real life this in 1996 we just sold a
hundred case on the Internet I do ship
it yeah like it was a logistics right
like I got into that you did what you
did you had that success you come over
you start hanging with me you start
every know these people
you know and you put me but here's what
happened you short spent come with me if
on you and I'm having need
how you that you will be great and
unstoppable and you're meeting some
people like wow why allow you sir
quitting this huge amount of pressure
look it's a huge amount this is why
prospects fail so I'm like you know I
feel like what's his name great this is
what you do to yourself it's not a
battement off here I'm aware that's what
I'm talking to you like like you know
you putting the pressure of all the
narrative that was built in a year that
we all jammed you just need to take a
little bit of a breath couple things I
can't oversell yourself on this decision
of twenty years old that I'm not capable
of building a business or I'm just a
creator and a Salesman is ludicrous but
just this you know it's you've won and
you trying to formulate what is social
media accounts into a media company yeah
you know like the people listen you know
one of the things that really happened
early on that I loved about you is when
I spoke to you early on about the one of
the every year you know when I spoke
when I spoke to you and I was and I was
like hey there's a big difference
between me and these hucksters like like
those voices that were getting in your
head I could see you being thoughtful
and not dismissing it as a [ __ ]
that's kind of what I feel about now
right look there's a fundamental
difference between building a media
company and having accounts on top of
social media networks on an arbitrage
that's that's it yes and that [ __ ]
matters and the ultimate is to do what I
do both right the elements of 42 and
make a lot of other millions of things
that happen so to me I genuinely believe
can do both really not want to I
definitely don't want you to do anything
for you know except for you yeah I just
want you to not go to Tina listen you
know I always believe the person
actually I think I did and I would say
funny that is here yesterday we were
working out and Jordan said to me the
favorite thing you've ever said or the
biggest thing I took away from you was
what Jordan yeah but what was it emotion
what was the quote oh the best part is
then letting your emotions dictate your
actions is the greatest sign of weakness
and that's what's happening right now
with you I want to take that variable
out a little bit and take it from the
tilt that it's on right now to at least
you know tipping 110 480 it still may be
right but we have to have this
conversation under 80 energy not 110 I
want to help you it makes me happy to
help you I care about you let me tell
you the most important thing you need to
hear from me you can literally decide
tomorrow to be 20 let all of this go to
zero
just listen to me and one big I
genuinely believe that good so honestly
if that's what you believe and I know
you believe that that needs to put you
in a very good place because then you
play with house money like I don't know
else to tell you and just the talent and
the earnings does already put in the
youth has put you in an incredible spot
the only thing that would recommend
please consider when you're in New York
to come and jam out of the office just
kind of hang good to see you thank you
- am i play my plan here is about three
meanings here my intuition is if I
finish this right now me or anything
I'll need as a Caesar salad that's my
plan today I do not you ate a lot
yesterday
Mussa less than I did the day before but
I didn't wear myself
I'm just not just nowhere to be had like
I mention Khan about 3-4 days ago like I
need to get you out of love and get me
focused and like yet like I have to
figure this out
I'm just not I need you to shadow me a
minute can you leave it did you matter
can you ask Mike to call Mike or see
them and ask him his perspective on his
hovering like what works best cuz I'm
gonna need to reset it yeah when it's
not there I feel amazing about today
only because I saw the number today I'm
like great accomplished nothing
some until the other way and because of
this dividing after this what if I can
get everything in there yes good so I
know this is my biggest win yeah when
I'm in New York you know yeah we're
gonna go to LA we just have to we just
have to take it seriously we I can't do
it myself
we can do myself I wouldn't hire you
guys yeah we're just not in the v game
so we just have to hack the conversation
I just had with dunk only so wait you're
grown up you're motivated but you know a
lot of great I'm I'm not gonna lose
weight it's not a tit job you know only
we can win as you face your demon
properly I'm not I don't think in the
two weeks I've had two days that were up
to the standard of what I would do just
know we're in the game yeah like I
should have had you like stay in the
house in a basement I'm like doing the
things that are wrong what should have
happened like if you're in it if we're
truly gonna lose 10 pounds you need to
be in the Hamptons every day you need to
be in the basement and you need to come
up and like [ __ ] Phoebe yeah that's
that's when I signed up for we've gotten
into such a place where we didn't have
to cuz it looked and so why put stress
on either one of us if it's working but
it's but I'm not winning the nutrition
game out there yeah nope okay
you know the whole like shadowing me and
being around thing we've never had to do
it he kind of came we never did right
the way I was intending on doing it
because I was coming off serious you
know fasting that I was going ladies
with muscle building so I was allowed to
eat so I was like why do I need him to
sit here or bother him and would it
bother to me but I think we have to go
to babysitting okay all right yeah so we
have to take it you know I don't need
you to babysit me for the next 16 months
but in my quest to lose some weight
which I'd like to because I'm my bigger
problem is if I was up in 67 I'd be okay
could be in a weight that's acceptable
to me that all that's happened is my
weights going up and I'm not I'm not in
a good rhythm and now I you know I you
know I kind of started talking about
coming months ago I always thought to be
easy it's just not I'm very [ __ ] how
long we been together two years like
year and a half into not eating that way
yeah yeah
and literally outside of getting sick in
Ghana which kind of like save you doing
that bad period I haven't shown anything
that makes me respect the way I'm going
about this yeah got it
understood and I feel it
once you can write yeah no not you can
tell everybody I can tell like content
are some pattern I used to be right you
can feel it tell you virus right
I see the my jawline to they see mm-hmm
I couldn't agree more
I've lost now I've got to win and I got
it back and I need you to we need to go
into a different gear yeah you suck have
flexibility who's gonna have to shadow
me cool at least when it matters right
and use Tyler and avi and like we're
just gonna have to hack yeah I'll see
you know they have it have a chat with
Mike jerk just because you might have an
insight that I don't know right um but
most of them have a chip talk with
yourself yeah cause it's life change for
you yeah at least four we just know it
stops like you've had so much you know
right now you're acting like a normal
client that people have 30 up right
that's what we're doing we're working
out what even I just
[Music]